as night fell in Shanghai they gathered
in their hundreds ordinary angry people
facing up to the authorities
they stood largely in silence words can
be dangerous here but there was a power
in them being withheld their presence
alone spoke volumes the roads are
completely blocked here by police
blocking the way to where protesters
gathered last night but that hasn't
stopped hundreds of other people
Gathering here holding up signs white
pieces of paper that's becoming a real
symbol of the protester
it's hard to express just how incredibly
unusual these scenes are in China
's rage is a fire on the other side of
this vast country covered rules
allegedly trapped those inside ten lost
their lives the final straw it seems for
many in a zero covered pressure cooker
among the crowd we met this group of
young friends brimming with passion and
Incredibly Brave
[Music]
[Applause]
with me
[Applause]
people spontaneously applauded her for
speaking and chanted freed the people
[Applause]
there's a sense that people are really
angry is that is that right
um people upset it's not really like
we're angry because there's other
countries our interview was suddenly cut
short by this
okay
police charging arresting everyone who
could run we got you
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go gradually police push the
crowds back and back but they did not
disperse
a heavy-handed Crackdown could well come
next the authorities have much to
concern them
protests like this are playing out
across multiple cities chance for the
ruling party to fall genuinely unheard
of some came with flowers they could not
lay and a clear message
[Music]
and you have hope that you're going to
achieve some of the change that you want
a male okay
scenes like this might be expected
elsewhere that they are not in China
everyone here is taking huge risks and
it is extraordinary
but nearly three years of covert
restrictions are wearing the party will
be watching but so too is the world
Helen Ann Smith Sky News in Shanghai